the president was briefed on the
wildfires in Canada last week and has
been regularly updated since he directed
his team to provide impacted communities
whatever support they need
our team here at the White House is in
touch with the government of Canada we
have already deployed over 600 U.S
firefighters and personnel as well as
equipment like water bombers to help
Canada battle the fires we also have
been in close touch with state and local
leaders including including in Michigan
Illinois and New York and multiple
agencies including the Environmental
Protection Agency CDC and FEMA are
coordinating with State local and tribal
governments to get timely and accurate
information out to communities about
local air quality conditions and what
steps they can take to protect
themselves we encourage everyone in the
impacted areas to listen to listen to
their state and local officials check in
on your neighbors check in on your your
friends and your family take precautions
especially if you are if you have health
conditions
you can also go to
airnow.gov that's
aairnow.gov again that's a
airnow.gov to get real-time information
about air quality and precautions you
can take
or download the app the airnow app from
the App Store as well you are able to do
that now I know for many communities out
west this is nothing new they experience
this every year but it is certainly
getting worse it is yet another alarming
example of the ways in which the climate
crisis is disturbing our lives and our
communities that's why from day one
President Biden rightfully recognized
the climate crisis climate change is one
of one of the four crises facing our
nation as he was coming into the Oval
Office
after being inaugurated and why he why
he made tackling climate change one of
his top priorities and has done historic
investments in doing just that taken
take it move forward with historic
historic policies and so with that I'll
go to the uh we'll continue to keep keep
up and continue to get updated on what's
Happening
um so the next thing I have here is I
also I wanted to take a moment to
highlight important progress states are
making with President Biden's full
support to make our community safer from
gun violence over the past week
Connecticut Vermont Colorado Hawaii have
all enacted Common Sense gun safety
bills that will save lives and here are
a few examples that's what's happening
in those particular States in
Connecticut Governor Ned Lamont signed a
gun violence prevention bill that will
strengthen safe storage requirements
close loopholes and the state's ban on
assault weapons expand accountability
for gun dealer and more and in Colorado
governor Jared Polis signed a law
cracking down on unciralized Firearms
known as ghost guns this progress comes
as 10 states and including DC have now
passed Statewide assault weapons ban
with every tragic shooting we see Across
America we see the urgency of action at
every level of our government the
president thinks and applauds The
Advocates and state leaders who work
tirelessly to enact these latest gun
safety measures and continue to urge
others to follow their lead when
Congress to act at the federal level
today the Council of economic advisors
released a Blog showing grocery
inflation is indeed slowing with prices
of eggs and produce such as vegetables
and fruit falling in recent months as
you know grocery prices Rose because of
the global supply chain bottleneck and
unforeseen Supply shocks like avian flu
and war in Ukraine and also poor weather
as we've worked to address those
bottlenecks and Supply shocks inflation
for groceries is indeed cooling of
course we still have a lot more work to
do as you hear from us from this
Administration which is why the
president's team is responding quickly
to avian flu outbreaks among bird
populations increasing competition in
meat industry and strengthening Supply
chains that were weakened by covet and
Putin's war in Ukraine
finally I'd like to make an announcement
that the president will welcome Yen
stoltenberg Secretary General of the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization also
known as NATO to the White House on
Monday June 12th to discuss the upcoming
NATO Summit that's going to be occurring
in Lithuania President Biden and
Secretary General stoltenberg will
review preparations for the summit
including the work to further strengthen
allied Allied deterrence and defense
built on the 2014 whale Summit Defense
investment pledge and deepened NATO's
partnership they will also discuss
allies support for Ukraine in the face
of Russia's brutal war of regression
with that good to see you good to see
you
um
Ukraine does the administration have any
better Insight on who or what caused the
collapse of the dam so look uh we're
still assessing what happened we're we
are indeed in touch with the ukrainians
it is the damage obviously and the
devastation station that we're seeing is
heartbreaking we will do everything that
we can to help the people of Ukraine
certainly but I'll say this and you've
heard to say this before just yesterday
Russia has no business to be there in
the first place and uh you know Russia
this was a this dam was under Russia's
control and they bear responsibility for
the destruction caused by this war and
we will do everything that we can to
support the people of Ukraine at this
difficult time in fact just have some on
the smoke is the White House in
particularly the president taking any
sort of further precautions just for
your own personal safety and it's just
going to change and all I know earlier
today at least it sounded like tomorrow
might be yours in the Washington area
and there's supposed to be a big event
on the south lawn as anything being
changed up at the White House in regards
to the pride event as you just mentioned
Omri which is going to be on the south
lawn tomorrow I don't have any logistic
legal updates to share at the moment but
of course we're going to continue to
monitor the situation just don't have
anything to share at this time as far as
if we're going to be changing our
approach here at the White House we just
don't have any changes and updates to to
report at this time
um just I guess to follow up on that has
been the president been advised to wear
a mask if he's outside given that the DC
air quality is code red today no I'm
aware that the DC uh quality is code red
and I would uh and for folks who are
watching uh at home or at work you can
go to the EPA certain the EPA website
and there's a map of what your area what
code color your area is I just don't
have anything to share on what the
president is going to be any changes to
how the president is going to be
approaching this so it doesn't have
anything at this time and two questions
if I can poet from yesterday does the
White House now have any reaction to the
merger of the PGA and live golf and did
this issue come up during secretary
Lincoln's meeting yesterday with the
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia so I can
say this uh the state department my
colleague at the state department they
put out a readout of the meeting that
secretary blinken had with the Saudi
Arabia government so I would refer you
to their readout I'm sure it's available
online at the state department so again
we're just not going to comment on this
deal we are that we're going to let the
two parties speak for themselves what
we're going to focus on from here is uh
is we're going to continue to meet our
commitment to the American people at
home and abroad and certainly certainly
that includes the Middle East as well
we're just not going to comment at this
time one more try at this some Senate
Democrats are not really happy with the
announcement of this merger the Senate
Finance chairman Ron weiden said they're
going to launch a comprehensive
investigation into this he said it looks
like a cash grab plan plain and simple
and it raises troubling questions does
the White House support Senate Democrats
which is that investigation we're just
not going to comment the house the
Congress is going to move forward the
way that they are going to move forward
is co-equal government as you all know I
just don't have an assessment on this I
don't have a comment on this this is a
private entity and we are being
consistent here on not commenting on the
actions of or mergers of private
entities
thanks Chris does the White House have a
position on whether Florida sending
migrants to California or any other
state for that matter is
amount to false imprisonment and
kidnapping of those migrants so one of
the things that you've heard me say this
multiple times uh from here is the about
what these political stunts and what
they mean they're dangerous and they're
unacceptable I said this yesterday and
I'll say this again and we've seen them
happen over the last couple of months
and all they do is cause confusion and
why is it they want to cause chaos and
confusion it doesn't make sense to me
and so unlawful border crossing as I
mentioned yesterday are down they're
down by 70 percent since the president
enacted his plan after title 42 was
lifted early uh or mid-may and so we're
addressing the challenges as we have
done we've done that through deterrence
we've done that through diplomacy and
we've done that through enforcement and
so again the plan that he's doing is is
working and and so I just don't
understand what are these Governors
doing why are they causing chaos why are
they causing confusion what does that
actually do for their constituency or
for the people who are being put on
these planes or on the buses and it just
doesn't make sense they're playing games
and political stunts just are not going
to actually deal with the issue at hand
and they can come they can come meet us
at the middle they can come and do a
bipartisan piece of legislation or look
at the legislation that the president
put forward on day one a comprehensive
immigration policy that he put forward
legislation why not look at that and
come to the table and have that
discussion with us instead of again
doing these political stunts and it
hurts it only hurts local governments it
only hurts other states and they're
doing this without reaching out to those
local government or states and it is
putting people at risk and it's
dangerous and again unacceptable or
addition perhaps to being a political
study to you think or does the White
House think that it's breaking the law
so look um
I'm gonna be careful here I cannot speak
to the law I know that I know comments
have been made about a particular
governor who's now a candidate uh who
has been accused of sending these
migrates so I want to be really careful
because he's a candidate so I want to
follow the Hatch Act so those are the
two governor no I just want to be I
still have to say this and be very very
careful and what I will say more about
his action
right I'm just also being clear that
he's also a candidate and so I want to
be careful and also just put that out
there for the American people but I will
say more broadly speaking if folks are
eager to see firsthand the significant
drop in unlawful border border crossings
since the president put in his plan and
that went into full effect uh you know
so it I mean that's what they need to
look at they need to look at the numbers
and the data that we have seen 70
that it's come down and so uh you know
it is uh
you know it is uh what they're doing is
completely uh completely dangerous and
so I cannot speak to the legal action I
cannot speak to if it's legal or not
what I can say causes confusion it's
dangerous and it is unacceptable and it
doesn't solve the actual problem that we
have at hand
Korean things um questions on two topics
but first I just want to quickly follow
up on the question about lip Golf and
and the PGA Tour Professor Biden has
been very direct in the past about
expressing his concerns about human
rights violations in Saudi Arabia about
the crown Prince's role in The Killing
of the journalists from alpha Sochi do
you really mean to say that you have no
comments on this massive investment by
Saudi Arabia taking a huge foothold in
one of the US's biggest Sports well
we've been very clear when it comes to
mergers when it comes to a private
entity we do not comment I mean that is
not that is not unnatural that is not
uncommon from us here at the White House
look when it comes to human foreign
we have been very clear if this
president has not shied away and calling
that out and he's done that with Saudi
Arabia he's done that with other
countries we've been very clear about
that we will speak out we do not shy
away from that and been again very very
clear when it comes to a merger
with these two entities that is
something that we're just not going to
comment on but when it comes to Human
Rights we've been very clear we're going
to call that out we are going to call
that out with countries just across the
globe and the president has done that in
these last two years
and then uh in terms of uh first topic
Dock Workers are disrupting operations
at Major West Coast International ports
over labor dispute the national retail
Administration is calling on the
administration to intervene in
negotiations to solve that labor dispute
we also have UPS workers that are
currently voting on whether or not to
strike if they don't have a new contract
by August 1st does the administration
plan to intervene in any of those labor
disputes so when it comes to the
Westport I can say that the president
respects the collective bargaining
process as the best weight for workers
and employers to reach mutually
beneficial Solutions which we have said
before and acting secretary Sue and
others in administration are regularly
engaging with the parties encouraging
them to stay at the negotiating table
and finish their work but the path
forward is for the port workers and
their employers to resolve the
negotiations so that workers get the
wages benefits and quality of life that
they so deserve and so that's what we're
going to continue to to call for asking
both parties to come to the table so
this can be uh so this can be dealt with
as it relates to the UPS you know we're
of course aware of the strike
authorization vote that that occurred uh
which is not a vote to go on strike but
again to be clear strike authorizations
votes sometimes occur during collective
bargaining to demonstrate the solidarity
of the union members in support of their
negotiation team so we're hopeful the
parties can reach an agreement and
satisfy both sides and so again the
president respects collective bargaining
process and he believes that the best
way for workers and employers to reach
an agreement that insures workers get
their fair fair benefits and quality of
life and wages that they deserve so
leave them Administration play an
effective role with an acting secretary
at the helmet remember this is an acting
secretary that was a deputy secretary
under uh under secretary Walsh for the
first almost two years and so we have
complete confidence in in acting
secretary Sue and she has as you know
strong relationships with these
different labor organizations and we we
believe that with her leadership uh
certainly uh she'll uh she'll she'll
engage in a way with the parties uh
that'll be effective and then real quick
this is not a question about to weigh in
on these presidential candidates I
understand you're going to respect the
Hatch Act but in terms of the
president's schedule and and how he's
been monitoring this you know we have
three new candidates for president of
the Republican race Mike Pence Chris
Christie governor Doug burgum is the
president monitoring these announcements
is he carving out any time in his
schedule to watch these announcements
any any thoughts on it well I can tell
you is the president's focused on the
American people that's his job that's
his job day in day out and you see that
as he talks about investing in America
as he talks about his economic policy
for American people as he as you saw him
do negotiate a fiscally responsible
bipartisan uh budget and that is going
to be his Focus is as it relates to the
campaign and schedule or what he's going
to be doing next certainly I would refer
you to his campaign or the DNC but I
know for sure the president is is zeroed
in and focused on the American people
and that's what he's going to continue
to do okay thanks when the president
walked from president
civil office today talks on Colony
outside do you know if he wore a mask
nobody is wearing a mask walking from on
The Colonnade
I'm just telling you I don't have any
changes to as I mentioned earlier I
don't have any changes to what he'll be
doing but we've been walking back and
forth on the colonnade and no one is
wearing a mask it's a short walk
um and then I question on the prime
minister's visit tomorrow can you give
us a little bit of a readout of what we
should expect from the the two leaders
um
there are certain things the president
is talking chocolate obviously this is
prime minister sunak's first visit to
the White House the two have met at
other locations but just wanted to hear
a little bit more about this they
certainly have met a couple times as you
just laid out Tyler a couple of things I
will lay out the president is looking
forward uh obviously to welcoming prime
minister sunac to the White House to
further deepen the close economic
relationship between United States and
United Kingdom and to discuss key
challenges and opportunities this will
be the fourth consecutive month the
president has met the Prime Minister
already this year they've met in
Hiroshima at the G7 in Belfast in April
and in San Diego in March at the August
trilateral event about our long-term
defense and security Partnerships in the
indo-pacific so during this visit
tomorrow the two leaders will review a
range of global issues including our
economic partnership our shared support
for Ukraine and it's and it defense as
it defends itself against Russia's
brutal war of aggression as well as
further action to accelerate the clean
energy transition the president and the
Prime Minister will also discuss the
joint us UK leadership on critical and
emerging Technologies Technologies as
well as our work to strengthen our
Economic Security they will also review
developments in Northern Ireland as part
of their shared commitment to preserving
the gains of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and certainly we will have
more to share and a readout once their
meeting occurs and ends tomorrow
sticking with the British prime
minister's visit one of the things that
he supposedly is going to bring up
during the meeting is this idea of a
creation of a global Watchdog agency
over AI is that something the president
thinks is needed is that something that
you would support so look uh you've
you've heard from the president and from
us on how we see this growing technology
Ai and we believe that how it moves
forward should be done in a responsible
way the vice president had a meeting
with the four CEOs recently the
president has held other other meetings
with his staff to discuss AI I'm not
going to get a ahead of what
conversation is going to be had during
this by lot that they're going to uh
that's going that they're going to have
tomorrow with the Prime Minister I'll
let them have their conversation we
certainly have a readout but we've been
very clear about how we see moving
forward with AI and how it needs to be
done in a responsible way we need to
make sure that we're protecting the
privacy of Americans and so we'll
definitely continue to speak to that
as it relates to the live PGA merger
yesterday the president was asked about
this merger during the cabinet uh
meeting and he said I'm going to be in
the PGA can you clarify had he been
briefed about the murder before was he
aware of what happened yes and what did
he mean then by was he just laughing off
the question I just think that he was
basically saying I'm not going to
comment
uh I'm wondering giving a close
relationship the president has developed
with him with him has there been any
Outreach to the Vatican or between the
two men themselves well obviously I
don't I don't have any call to read out
but obviously our thoughts are with uh
with the Pope and certainly we are
hoping that he has a full and quick uh
recovery and then under announcement
about the secretary General's visit in a
couple weeks has the president ruled out
asking Mr sultenberg to extend his
tenure again with NATO and is this a
subject that you might raise with the
Prime Minister tomorrow president prime
minister sunac has been advocating for
his defense minister as a potential
successor so I'm not going to get ahead
of the conversation that they're going
to have I can say and we've said it here
yesterday that the president believes
that the secretary has been has done and
it's outstanding outstanding job a
superb job as a as Secretary General
especially in this critical moment in
history leading the alliance that we
have responded to in response to
Russia's war in Ukraine and so we're
very very grateful for his leadership
I'm not going to get into speculation
from here I'm not going to get into what
the process or how the president is
thinking about the next steps here but
certainly we are incredibly incredibly
grateful uh to the to the Secretary
General
I'm just going to go on again thanks
Karina so you noted in your topper that
climate change is making wildfires worse
just put a finer point on that should
the public expect this kind of thing to
be happening more often parts of today's
covered with smoke so look I I'm not an
expert I can't predict how this is going
to move forward or how this is going to
look in the future but certainly we've
seen I mentioned the West Coast has
dealt with this for some time so this is
not uncommon sadly it's only getting
worse but this is why the president has
made climate change a priority this is
why he's taking the aggressive actions
that he's taking historic actions and
he's certainly going to continue to uh
to stay focused on how we move forward
in dealing with climate change but again
I'm not an expert but clearly as we have
seen over the last couple of decades
climate change has been a real problem
it is the science that shows us that it
isn't when the Secretary of Lincoln goes
to China is it the president's
goal or hope that he meets directly with
President XI and is that sort of what
the conversations that are happening
behind the scenes are so I'm not going
to certainly not gonna get ahead of what
uh what a conversation or what uh what
that will look like the president has
said uh he wants to talk to president XI
certainly don't have a a call to preview
for all of you at this time and as it
relates to uh secretary blinken I would
refer you to the state department but we
have said uh you know we're hoping that
uh that he will be able to travel to
China when when the time is right just
don't have anything at this time
thanks uh one follow-up on Ukraine Dam
situation you said that you're still
assessing who's responsible but can you
say in your conversations with the
ukrainians what they're telling you in
terms of what additional Aid they might
need to respond to this situation and
will the president uh be discussing it
with prime minister sunak tomorrow and
then separately is there any plan at all
for the president to talk to president
zielinski and if not why not so of
course
Ukraine is going to be at the top of
discussion uh tomorrow it is NATO and as
you know NATO the NATO alliance has been
strengthened because of the president's
uh because of the president's leadership
and so of course Ukraine and Russia will
be top of mind and discuss I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go into details of what
they're going to be talking about
certainly we'll have a readout that will
lay lay more of the conversation I don't
have any specifics to share on what the
conversations that were had with Ukraine
in regards to the dam I just I could
just tell you we've been in touch and
we're ready to help and any way that we
can just don't have a don't have a list
of what they're asking for what was
discussed
[Music]
before on the hill that three months ago
Jake Sullivan came out in support of and
then we haven't really heard much since
can you say whether you're working at
all with the hill on making this become
law are you working with the Senate the
house or have you sort of given up on
any authority to restrict Tick Tock and
other apps that you think are so good it
certainly this is important to the
president to the administration this
type of legislation that Jake talked
about a couple months ago don't have an
update for you we are always in constant
contact on different pieces of
legislation with the house and the
Senate I just don't have an update on
where we are currently with this
particular legislation
that's great
um so Walgreens unveiled a new look for
their stores they unveiled that in
Chicago and it has basically everything
locked up uh in part because of the
theft that they've seen uh recent study
shows that uh 50 of retail workers have
seen some sort of retail theft and
another nearly 50 percent are afraid to
go to work so is the president aware of
retail theft and how come the problems
become so
pervasive under his attention so look
what I can tell you is unlike
Congressional Republicans the president
has taken action he has taken action to
deal with uh with uh with the crime
hiring police officers we've seen that
from his actions that he's taken to cut
crime and he uh and it started with the
American Rescue plan the American Rescue
plan had billions of dollars that went
into communities to hire police officers
uh to it to to make sure that we held we
had accountability as well on the ground
and let's not forget his safer American
plan to fund the police and invest in
crime and prevention so we have taken
actions we have made sure that we do
everything that we can to try and
protect communities and to make sure
that police officers are hired and so
look instead of Congress uh you know
passing legislation or wanting to cut or
defund the police we're doing the
opposite and so we would love to work
with Congress and see how else we can be
helpful to communities but the president
has taken action again the American
Rescue plan the safer communities safer
Community America plan and he's going to
continue to do what he can to make sure
that we keep communities safe about the
visit tomorrow the United Kingdom left
the EU in 2020 the UK remains our
closest Ally or one of our closest
allies as you said how come we're not
negotiating a trade deal with them so
look I think in that conversation that
they'll have tomorrow for sure uh the
economy will be uh part of that
conversation uh look they have the
largest bilateral investment
relationship in the world when you think
about the UK and United States and
that's a source of strength and has been
an important foundation of economic
growth over the years in both of our
countries and so I'm sure when the two
leaders meet they will take they will
continue to take steps to deepen that
economic partnership and so I'm not
going to get ahead of what the president
and the Prime Minister are going to
speak to but again they have one of the
strongest largest bilateral investment
relationship in the world and I think
that matters
the president comfortable with the UK
leading on artificial intelligence
because that's one of the things the
prime ministers look I'm not going to
get ahead of again what they're going to
discuss I've laid out where we what we
have done here and how we see moving
forward on artificial intelligence but
again I'm just not going to get ahead of
it we'll have a readout tomorrow
experience uh you mentioned the
government's U.S and Canada working
together talking about the wildfires but
has President Biden spoken with uh prime
minister Trudeau about this any any
offers of anything different that has
not already been offered or long-term
plans they've been discussing so I can
tell you this our Deputy National
Security adviser Liz Sherwood Randall
has been in touch with her counterparts
and she has been for the since last week
in offering it and listening to them and
off making sure we're offering any
assistance that they might need we
mentioned the 600 plus firefighters and
Personnel that we have provided to
Canada to help them deal with this
Wildfire I don't have a call to read out
between the Prime Minister and the
president we've also as I mentioned been
in touch with Governors and and local
government as well to make sure that we
are offering any assistance that they
might need can I also just ask is the is
the president watching watching uh some
of the pushback from kind of more
conservative Republicans uh in the house
regarding the debt ceiling though
they're concerned does he have any
thoughts about that effort and also how
it might impact future dealing with the
house look and I mentioned this last
week even earlier this week the
president has done has signed more than
350 bipartisan pieces of legislation
signed them into law and I think that
shows how the president has been able to
work work with Congress in a bipartisan
way and I think that's important and we
hope that continues because there's so
much more that needs to be done as far
as lowering costs making sure the
wealthy pay their fair share there's a
list of things that we would love to
work in a bipartisan way with Congress
and so the president certainly he's an
optimist he believes that we can
continue to do that work and certainly
we're going to try as it relates to what
Congress is saying or congress
Congressional Republicans are saying
look this was a bipartisan fiscally
responsible piece of legislation it was
important to the American people we
believe they they are the ones that won
because we're able to protect some of
the programs that they truly need just
to make ends meet we're able to protect
some of the all of the historic pieces
of legislation that the president put
forward to deal with an economy that
doesn't leave anybody behind so the
president is very proud of what he was
able to do with speaker McCarthy and the
other leaders and we hope that type of
bipartisanship continues uh certainly
I'm not going to get into hypotheticals
of how that's going to look down the
road but we have a record we have a
record in the last two years to show
that we have been able to get that done
thank you I wanted to ask you about we
are two weeks away from the state visit
secretary Austin was in Delhi this week
and I guess there's some other high
profile visits happening between them
now and then put defense be an important
part of the
discussions with President Prime
Minister Modi and President Biden say
that last part defense be an important
part of discussions between the two
leaders oh defense so look I I don't
have anything more to say at this time
about the visit as we get closer
certainly we will have more to share
what I've said is the upcoming visit we
believe will affirm the deep and close
partnership between the United States
and India and the warm bonds of family
and friendship that link Americans and
Indians together so that is incredibly
important the Prime Minister and the
president will discuss ways to
strengthen our two countries share a
commitment to free open prosperous and
secure indo-pacific and our shared
resolve to elevate our strategic
technology partnership including defense
so that certainly will be talked about
in clean energy in space but I'm just
not going to get into details on what
the particulars will be and as we get
closer to June 22nd we certainly have
more to share
have the
slits gone out for the state dinner and
the welcome ceremony how big so as you
know we've done about this will be our
third state dinner we usually don't
release those guest lists until closer
to the date and so I suspect that we
will do we will do the same process with
this sense of number of people I don't
have a number to share
decided the menu and the entertainment
I don't have anything to share wait what
is today it's like so early
uh we still have about two weeks left
and we that's plenty of time and that's
like multiple years in this in these
types of administration and presidential
administrations uh so as soon as we have
more to share we certainly will but I
wouldn't uh I wouldn't expect that it
will happen uh before the week of the
actual uh actual event
okay John thanks a lot free yesterday
the World Bank issued a report in which
they indicated that the global economy
is slowing down dramatically they're
forecasting an annualized a rate of
growth of just 2.1 percent for this
coming year is that something that you
agree with you see the U.S economy
similarly slowing down at a substantial
rate so I haven't seen the report
certainly I have to talk to the our
Economist about the report that you're
speaking to what I can share with you is
what we're doing here and how we think
it is going to be important to
strengthening the global economy right
in making sure that the debt limit was
dealt with I think that was an important
way to dealing with the global economy
having a a bipartisan important budget
negotiation that was clearly signed into
law that is incredibly important because
you were protecting jobs protecting
retirement accounts for Americans which
is what the president was was able to do
making sure people stay on their health
care and protecting other incredibly
important programs like veteran programs
for example Social Security Medicare so
because of the work that this president
has done the last two years and just
most recently we are in a better place
with our economy with the American
economy I would have again would have to
speak to the economists about this
particular piece of data that you're
sharing economy has been incredibly
resilient uh do you expect that can to
continue uh over the course of the
remainder of this year and what is it
that this White House can do to prevent
this slow down in the economy given the
fact that there is a divided Congress so
look uh and you're right the U.S economy
has been very resilient and that is a
lot because of the the actions that this
president has taken and making sure that
we turned the economy around from when
he walked in as you know it was a crisis
and so we've been saying this we've been
saying that we believe that we're we're
transitioning to a more steady a state
growth stable growth and that's what
we're seeing when you look at the job
numbers that come out every month and
that's what we believe we're headed to
and so the president's certainly going
to continue to do he's going to now
Implement those historic pieces of
legislation where it's going to create
more jobs and it's going to help
continue to make sure that the economy
stays resilient
the uh the minority leader in the Senate
Mitch McConnell has said that the budget
caps for defense spending in the budget
agreement are insufficient to meet the
challenges as it relates to Russia Iran
China
um does the president share those
concerns and does the president intend
to submit any sort of supplemental
spending package as it relates to either
bumping up defense spending or
specifically providing additional
military assistance for Ukraine so as
the president said last week and I'll
quote him he said if there's any
existential need for additional funding
I have no doubt we'll be able to get it
that's what the president said when when
the budget agreement was done we have
been grateful for the widespread
bipartisan support for Ukraine and
expect that to continue uh and uh and so
it doesn't rule out the budget agreement
does not rule out additional emergency
funding whether it is for Ukraine or
extreme weather and so the president is
very confident on that as you know there
is now an Appropriations process as uh
as director young spoke to certainly not
we are now in back in regular order
right which is why it was important
about getting this budget agreement done
so I'm going to let the appropriation
process move forward not going to get
ahead of that but the president as he
stated himself he is he's confident so
more generally speaking he is okay with
where the budget caps are for defense
look there's an Appropriations process
that's going to get going that is
regular order that is where we're
supposed to be we're going to let that
process go as you're asking me about
more defense funding as the minority
leader as you just stated feels like
there's not enough in defense the
president has said he if there is if
there is need existential need to
additional funding he believes that we
will get there so that's what I can
share with you on that part
let me see good Alex I haven't called
anyone
um hi Karina um United States um as you
know has a far higher incidence of car
fatalities both the drivers and
pedestrians cyclists and almost all I
think all other lovely Nations and we're
about to enter the most dangerous time
of the year for car accidents the
several months is this Administration
done enough on that front
um or has maybe the I don't know the the
automotive the highway Lobby sort of had
its way as it has had with many other
Administrations
so look look right we Face a crisis here
in America when it comes to when it
comes to driving passengers drivers
passengers pedestrian cyclists each year
more than 40 000 people
have to die in these types of crashes
and so uh and this is uh comparable to
gun deaths and it should not be this way
so the Department of Transportation
launched a national roadway safety
strategy in early of 2022 to tackle this
type of crisis at every level and so
while it's encouraging to see the debts
level has kind of the death leveling off
uh somewhat in the last two quarters
because we have seen that occur it is no
time to let up and so we're going to
D.O.T is going to continue to take major
steps to keep people safe and I think
that's important again they've put a
plan together to try to tackle this
incredibly uh unfortunate situation
okay I know you won't comment on the
case involving the president's son but
the president previously criticized the
Supreme Court ruling that his legal team
is preparing to use should he be charged
as an affront to Common Sense and the
Constitution I just want to know if that
statement from June of last year still
holds or if he is viewing that ruling in
a new light I'm just not going to
comment on this
and on the merger The Wall Street
Journal editorial board said this is
more than just a private deal it's
really about MBS sort of thumbing his
nose at the president
um they point out that
the Saudis entered a China broker deal
with Iran they are cozing up to Maduro
cut oil production ahead of Lincoln's
visit helping Russia driving up prices
hurting Biden and they write is Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin some
on trolling President Biden call it the
Revenge of the Pariah I can't comment to
uh or lay out what the thinking of of
the Saudi Arabia official or government
are as it relates to this merger we're
just not going to comment on this deal
it is uh two private entities and we're
just not going to come back making the
president look weak if there's no
comment when you have Democratic
senators saying that the president's
justice department should be looking at
this with respect to antitrust questions
foreign registration questions
doesn't know comment fall short it's
first of all the president does not look
weak this is a president because of his
leadership has brought together uh our
allies and partners again which uh
certainly was our our foreign policy
relationship with heads of States was
gutted and destroyed by the last
Administration and this is the president
that has been able to strengthen NATO
alliance again because of his leadership
has been able to bring more than 50
countries together to help support
Ukraine as they're battling the
aggression from Russia and that is
occurring because of this president's
leadership and so I think that is
important and because we're saying that
we're not going to speak to a private
merger a company's merger a private
entity does not make the president weak
though right it does not make the
president of course he's going to be
briefed on he's the president of the
United States but it does not but that
we're not going to comment on it because
it is a private entity we've been
consistent we've been consistent he's
the president of the United States he he
gets to know everything that's going on
in the in the world in the country right
that is important for him to know he is
he's one of the leaders of the Free
World to get briefed on privacy
I've answered your question we're going
to move on Courtney you will the
president withdraw his nomination of the
alcohol from judgeship in the southern
district of New York today's culture
vote in the Senate is canceled so the
president is proud to have put him
forward and we're going to continue uh
to support his nomination do you have an
expectation of when and when another
vote will be
okay
thank you so much I have two questions
about events at the White House tomorrow
firstly on the sunac visit
um the Prime Minister has echoed some of
President Biden's strong words on Taiwan
so I'm wondering if the two leaders are
going to discuss related China issues
like Investments semiconductors Supply
chains and is it a priority for the
administration to get us UK alignment on
these issues just not going to get ahead
of their conversation tomorrow I just
laid out what they're looking forward to
particular particularly discussing this
is the fourth time that they've met in
four months and it is a it is a a our
closest relationship an important
relationship especially as we talk about
Ukraine and and the war in Ukraine that
was clearly an aggression by Russia I'm
just not going to get into specifics of
what what they're going to speak about I
talked about the economy I talked about
Ukraine and certainly and clean energy
which is going to be incredibly
important but just not going to go into
any more specifics and we'll certainly
have a readout then moving on to the
pride event tomorrow this likely to
provoke some political or politicized
pushback especially from you know some
of the states that have passed
legislation targeting sexual minorities
or from countries that have done the
same so could I just hear from you why
does the White House feel that this
event is important especially in this
context so we've had multiple events
celebrating the lgbtq plus Community
multiple and this is the president that
has been a strong Ally a vice president
that has been a strong Ally a second
gentleman a first lady that has been a
strong Ally of the of the community and
it is important he feels it is important
they feel is important to lift up a
community to lift up their
accomplishments and what they've been
able to do for the community and so we
think it's an important moment and let's
not forget what we're seeing across the
country from State houses more than 600
pieces of legislation anti-lgbtq plus
legislation a few hundred of those are
against transgender Youth and so we have
not seen that type of
anti-sentiment anti against this
community in decades and so we believe
that not only does this community need
to be celebrated and continue to be
celebrated as he's done many times
before in this in this past two years
but we also need to make sure that we
let the community know that the
president has their back and we're going
to continue to fight for them and so
that is important I think that is
important to be able to bring a couple
of thousand Americans here to the White
House to let them know that this
President is going to continue to fight
for them and that's the message that we
want to make sure that gets out there
uh
I haven't been oh on the issue of Asylum
Seekers arriving in New York uh recently
Governor Hogle and New York city mayor
Adams
um you know press called upon the
federal government the Biden
Administration to somehow work
um on relaxing some of the work
permitting requirements easing
restrictions so that some of these
Asylum Seekers can get their work
permits before
um this uh six-month waiting period I'm
wondering if the White House has any
update on that any you know just stance
on on those discussions so I don't have
any updates on the work requirements I
know that's been in the news for some
time now what I will say is that we have
uh have had Direct Communications and
conversations with these interior cities
and states we're dealing with uh with an
influx of immigrants in their city in
their state and we've had very multiple
conversations not just with New York but
also Chicago and other again other
interior cities and states and what I
will say is that we have we have offered
assistance and resources I have
announced and I've and it's been
announced not just be by me but by DHS
the more than 200 million I believe more
than 300 million of resources to those
uh to those particular interior States
and also I have said even said this
yesterday that a a large piece of that
has been provided to New York and so
we're going to continue to have those
conversations we're going to continue to
assist the best way that we can as we
have been doing for the past several
months
we had Owen in the back good afternoon
free in Chicago over Memorial Day
weekend
50 people were shot several killed in
separate incidents
and I know that you discussed the action
this Administration has taken to try to
reduce gun violence but I want to know
what the president has to say to
individuals Chicago residents living in
neighborhoods where bullets are flying
and can't wait for laws to take effect
what the president would tell that
person we'll say that we are doing
everything that we can
to make sure their communities are safe
and the president and it's not just our
words our actions show that the
president signed into uh two two dozen
almost two more than two dozen executive
actions to deal with gun violence and
the president has also continued to call
on Congress to take additional action we
are very proud of the bipartisan piece
of legislation on gun violence to pursue
fight gun violence that was signed just
about a year ago and that was something
that we had not seen in 30 years and
because of the president's leadership we
were able to get that done the President
also has made clear that Congress needs
to do more and so he's taken action and
certainly our hearts go out to families
or individuals who have lost loved ones
it is uh it is devastating to see when
you hear a statistic where guns is is is
the uh is guns are are is or what is
taking the lives of our children the
number one killer of our children
children that's devastating to hear that
is something that the president wants to
prevent and wants to deal with which is
why he took those actions so we're going
to continue to call on Congress to take
action and and I will say and will be
very loud about that and very clear
about that and I will also say again our
hearts go out to folks who have lost
loved ones to gun violence okay Brian I
wanted to ask about Ukraine and NATO uh
the British prime minister Richard sunax
last week said that Ukraine's rightful
place is in NATO will this be something
that the two discuss when they eat
tomorrow
look I'm not going to get into specifics
of what's going to happen again I know
you guys have asked me a couple of
questions but our commitment to NATO's
open door policy stands and so just not
going to get ahead of that
the meeting tomorrow and that the NATO
Secretary General is going to be here on
Monday is President Biden thinking about
A Renewed push toward Ukraine's
admission into NATO I mean we've been I
mean nothing has changed of how we've
answered this question before uh you
know an alliance decision is between the
31 allies and uh and aspirin country
that's how it's dealt with you have to
there's a process and there's an open
door policy that's what we support we've
been we've supported that for some time
now but right now we are focused on
making sure that Ukraine has everything
that it needs to fight Russia's
aggression and you heard us just about
last week announce another PDA of 300
million dollars we're going to continue
to do that every other week or so and
continue to show our support for Ukraine
whether it is Aid or systems and uh and
you know we've done that the last 15
months and so we're going to you know
we're going to do everything that we can
to support the Ukrainian people as they
fight in a incredibly impressive and
brave a brave fight
um you said repeatedly here that the
winners didn't want to comment on a
private entity
quick search back through briefings in
recent months fines that you commented
on JP Morgan's merger or purchase of
First Republic and then you were asked
last November about Elon Musk buying
Twitter saying we're going to keep an
eye on that decision decision did not
comment today have anything to do with
the fact that secretary of state is in
Saudi Arabia right now no not at all not
at all we're just not going to comment
on this and uh and
look I also said with the mer the the uh
the Elon Musk I also said the same thing
that I said today is that we're not
going to comment uh on a private entity
I actually said those words as we talked
about Elon Musk and Twitter and so
that's going to continue we're not going
to comment on this we're going to focus
on the American people we're going to
focus on uh on what their needs are as
it relates to uh you know American
families and as it relates to abroad and
also uh the Middle East as well and so
that's the president's Focus right now
but I've always been very clear we just
are not not going to comment on on any
types of mergers and I know you pulled
out those those specific things but I
also continued and said I'm just not
going to comment on mergers or private
entities